hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday uh June 25th 2018 what's going on
oh wow yeah how you doing how you doing
with the the summer the summer's here
right we're in the twin the 20s of June
somewhere along the lines the first day
of summer you know back in the day used
to know it right because there wasn't as
many channels and you would watch the
local news and they'd bring it up
tonight is the first day of summer
tell us jack what can people look
forward to weather-wise well I'll tell
you bike we got a low pressure system
coming in so don't inflate those [ __ ]
above-ground pools yes yep and then
they'd laugh for no reason huh your
weekend's gonna suck anyways it's got to
be the summertime right the [ __ ]
sun's out there you go right there
global warming what'd you do this
weekend I have a couple of cause like
that's this generations Budweiser right
Coors Light that crushing it you know
Peyton Manning's [ __ ] up you notice
the second Peyton Manning [ __ ] bought
Budweiser now it's second place you know
he didn't buy it he bought into it the
second he [ __ ] got it I bet he
started pointing fingers at everybody
you know we got we heard from Hop issues
right and all of a sudden nobody's
getting along over there and Coors Light
now Coors light's ahead all right
I bet Tom Brady invested in Coors Light
sorry why would I do this
I like Peyton Manning now that he's
retired you know I could look back and
be like you know what that fella was
quite a quarterback but when they're
playing against your team you hate him
stupid you know you don't hate them
you just hate him it's weird
anyways the summer's here I am back from
vacation Saul and I'm getting ready this
weekend Oh freckles shaking off the
cobwebs I'm gonna be in Minneapolis
Minnesota in Detroit Michigan okay
couple uh Joe Sixpack towns
you know where they put that pet well
legged at that looking forward to that
and so I'm gonna be around la doing a
bunch of spots shaking off the dust I'm
on the elliptical working off the plus
all paw no Chocolat I never had any of
those you know my wife's into those
[ __ ] things I like I like the plain
old boring white guy croissant
I don't need any flavor anyways oh my
god I don't want to talk about this
early on but I have to out of respect
it's a sad sad sad sad day the passing
of the great Vinnie Paul drummer of
obviously Pantera damageplan and hell
yeah good lord what of what a loss can't
even can't even put it into words
and I was lucky enough to meet him he
was a big comedy fan I remember the
first time I met him I was opening for
the late great Charlie Murphy this is
what happens when you get older like
half your stories it's like perhaps the
people in him are like [ __ ] dead it
sucks but anyways yeah me Charlie and
Donnell or on tour and we did the
Addison improv and I remember that that
was one of those shows one of the few
times I ever
I went over without even realizing it I
always knew when I was going over but I
did like 40 minutes and I was supposed
to like 25 it's just one of those days
what there was talking and I don't know
what happened and Charlie was cool with
it but I was embarrassed because I never
do that [ __ ] and it's a real kunti thing
to do and it's something you know makes
the headliners job more difficult
because you ate up all of that extra
time wearing them out and all of that
[ __ ] so I do remember that from that
weekend but one of those shows it wasn't
the show when I went over but uh I was
standing after the show selling my CDs
this is how long ago this was it was
right around it was 2004
his brother was still alive and I was
just standing there and I just looked up
and even he was standing
there if any [ __ ] Paul and you know
it wasn't like he was Vinnie Paul
offstage he just was Vinnie Paul he had
the [ __ ] cowboy hat on
you know this shirt with flames on it
and [ __ ] these crazy cowboy boots and he
was just standing there the big smile on
his face and I was just like oh I mean
this guy's like guy saw him to cover a
Modern Drummer I couldn't believe it it
was like I was like holy [ __ ] you
[ __ ] Vinnie Paul just started
laughing and you know was super
complimentary about the show and all
that and then he invited us out he had
his own club out there gentlemen's club
then we all went out there and he was
nice enough ice actually sat with him in
his club for like 45 minutes like a
total drum nerd and asked him all of
these questions about drum parts that he
did and like who were the guys that he
listened to and and you know I asked I
was like you know who do you think like
one of the underrated drummers out there
and he was like oh Alex Van Halen you
know and we went went on and on about
him and it's kind of ironic because I
really feel that Vinnie and dime bag
where the Eddie and Alex I should say
Alex and Eddie of their generation and
it just sucks man he was just such a
nice guy and then after that he probably
came out to two or three other shows and
he always was smiling always was just
the greatest nicest guy and it's I don't
know one of the reasons why I never got
into double bass playing was because so
many people I just felt like once like
oh they all their fills everything was
just the [ __ ] feet and their hands
stunk and it didn't groove it just was
going 9 zillion miles an hour and you
know it was impressive to look at but it
didn't it didn't give me the chills
didn't make me want to do it and he was
a guy that changed that and I when I
listened to him play my younger brothers
were into Pantera I [ __ ] up I never
saw him remember one of my brothers went
to go see him was telling me how amazing
the show is
to be honest with you like I I just you
know concerts were different back then
you could get [ __ ] up at a concert and
there was no cell phone footage she just
got [ __ ] up and that was it and there
was like mosh pits like it just it had
changed and I got a little bit older I
was in my mid-20s basically when they
came around and I had already started
doing stand-up and [ __ ] and you know I
remember going to a couple uh you know
concerts like ac/dc and [ __ ] and people
were doing blow and it was you know it
was a little [ __ ] you know there was
you you had to be like a certain level
of [ __ ] up just so you could stay
relaxed so you could kind of navigate it
you know what I mean you couldn't be
sitting there looking [ __ ] nervous
and I would you know and that was just
at like ac/dc which was always like a
fun show so like what this Pantera came
and it was a new level of aggression and
anger certainly you know with Phil
singing I had never heard anything like
that and you know just the way I was
just I just had this feeling my I was I
was too afraid I was am I [ __ ] got to
go down there
my [ __ ] orange hair trying to grow it
out and it just gets bigger and bigger
and it looked like Bernie from room 222
and there's a mosh pit I'm gonna get
this you know how I always got over with
people was making him laugh and the show
was gonna be too [ __ ] loud so if they
were just gonna look at me the way I
looked I mean I would I just felt like
it wasn't gonna go well so I was a fan
from afar and I really [ __ ] up by not
seeing those guys and I remember when
Vinny came down on the show he said hey
you know I got this this new this new
band I think it was it was it was
damageplan he said we'll play in New
York and I said he goes he goes I'll
hook you up I said really said dude he
goes you can [ __ ] stand right behind
me while I play the whole show and of
course I had some [ __ ] Road gig when
they came to town I think Florentine
went because I remember talking to him
about it I was so [ __ ] envious that
he got to go and I I didn't get to go so
I never saw him play live but um you
know since doing that deen dayal ratio
where i had to learn how to play butcher
this song by trying to learn how to play
that song by
the crew livewire which had the double
bass you know basic thing in there since
then I've just kind of gotten addicted
to it and was listening to all of
Pantera stuff and a whole nother like
level and you know Cowboys from Hell and
[ __ ] broken and this love just loving
the drum parts are just so [ __ ]
perfect in all of those and I was just
talking I was talking to my drum teacher
literally that day of how great Vinnie
Paul was with his work in that band and
and then like it [ __ ] was so weird
that night that hope said I got that
text I couldn't [ __ ] believe it and
super sad but I don't like the only good
thing I could say is that got the mark
that the guy left is he won't be
forgotten and obviously his brother
hasn't been so anyways that's my little
my little point of view on truly one of
the great artists that I ever heard or
got this I don't know listen to whatever
hang out with her or anything so so that
sucks
and that said so I don't know where the
[ __ ] to go from here how do you turn it
back to being funny you know can I talk
about the Germans playing the Swedes in
the [ __ ] do they play Sweden is that
it was it by the the shirts for the same
colors they're flagged so I always [ __ ]
that up Sweden and Switzerland because
I'm an American and we never they never
taught us geography like that and I
don't one time I did a gig in Sweden and
I said hey it's great to be here in
Switzerland and they all laughed
thinking I was joking and I honestly
[ __ ] it up and I just rolled with it I
was like hey just [ __ ] with you they
both start with SW but I did the whole
Thank You Cleveland whatever the [ __ ] it
was a spinal tap thank you
I gotta get back there I haven't done
what would you call that Hitler's ranch
up there Norway Sweden and Finland all
those places when he used to look across
the boys at the Baltic Sea I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is just look across
that water there well that's is what
should look like yeah frolicking in the
grass anyways
hello swing did you know they date they
were noncommittal in World War two ended
up being a great [ __ ] move not
socially it wasn't a good move but it
was a great [ __ ] move financially
because just for the fact that they were
still standing after World War Two and
never got bond you know let the let the
let the Krauts [ __ ] use their train
to go in in Norway they stood there
their [ __ ] Applebee's was still open
at the end of it you know so I mean I
guess you can learn something from
Sweden when when [ __ ] is hitting the fan
and you need to stand up and make a
stand
don't let let other people do it just
kind of sit back and see who wins it and
carry on anyways so the Swedes of play
in Germany right I'm mostly German so I
usually root for Germany but whatever
all right I just root for an underdog
like isolate I mean how you're not
[ __ ] root for Iceland you know Poland
and [ __ ] like that you know I'm rooting
for all anybody other than the
powerhouses that always seem to be in
and I don't know [ __ ] about soccer so
this is what its gonna make it funny but
anyway so I'm watching this [ __ ] game
and this Swedish dude right yeah he's on
a [ __ ] breakaway what ya going he's
all alone right and then this guy in the
German team a black dude which is
hilarious you know what I mean I was
always just sitting like like how
conflicted would Hitler be Germany won
but this is that's out Sam he comes down
and goes to not only went to like trip
the guy he also couldn't like just
pushed him from behind and like a
[ __ ] referee and the WWE somehow this
guy didn't see it I mean I think it
happened in the Box in the painted area
whatever the [ __ ]
call it in that sport and I think that
that should have just been one of those
[ __ ] penalty kicks where the goalie
just dives and guesses one side but
anyways the Swedes ended up going up one
nothing and the Germans tied it up and
then this guy he did the old Bend It
Like Beckham he did the old [ __ ]
roundabouts there I don't know how to
talk about the sport but I got to tell
you something I actually I love making
fun of soccer but I have to watch it in
order to make fun of it and now having
watched it I'm actually I kind of love
it now and I kind of understand the
beauty of the game finally I'm starting
to get it and it is really cool that it
is so hard to score that when it happens
that people absolutely lose their
[ __ ] mind so I am on board I'm going
to continue to make fun of it I had it
on in the background and you know I had
like [ __ ] two weeks of mail here that
I was going through and and I times that
I just kept looking over at the TV
because he knows he'd be like oh he's
gonna be sick so I was in at the table
going like oh my god oh something I
almost happened that's what it just
seemed like but it really is a great
game
G bill you really you know you mean the
rest of the world is right bill and you
might be wrong on this one but I missed
it today a good friend of mine wrote in
wrote in sent me a text and podcast mode
she sent me a text message and asked me
if I saw the England play today I guess
they played a great game and I heard
Mexico at a pretty scrappy game with the
Koreans I heard it was getting a little
nasty they're like the Koreans were
desperate like we don't give a [ __ ] you
know we can't score unless we have the
ball and you know I guess Mexico's fast
that's what I know and I promise you
this week I'm going to neglect all my
responsibilities and I'm gonna try to
watch some of this [ __ ] cuz uh it is it
is [ __ ] once every four years the
entire world get
together to play for an actual World
Championship is pretty that's pretty
sick you know I just wish I could use
their hands you just see that one Connie
[ __ ] jumped over the guy and
accidentally kicked him in the face I
mean it's got to be like kicking a guy
in the ground in the face in the realm
of like losing your man card forever
like who [ __ ] who does that with your
shoes on at least she could be barefoot
so maybe make your foot sting a little
bit I would be so disappointed if I had
a [ __ ] son and he ended up playing
soccer first of all I'd be happy for his
brain but you know if that's what he did
you gonna frolic down the field and jump
in the air like some baby deer and then
kick somebody in the face no I think the
guy does he takes out a yellow card I
hate the way they take it out and the
guy just stands up in front of the guy
stupid thing up in the air like he's
bidding on a [ __ ] Shelby anyways
congratulations to anybody who won I got
to get into it sorry I did watch the the
f1 finally I was in town I got to watch
i watch the French GP congratulations to
Lewis Hamilton max Verstappen was
[ __ ] hilarious in the press
conference afterwards cuz Vettel slammed
into botas de Max was gone you know I
think he needs you guys should tell him
he needs to adjust his style because
they were given max [ __ ] you know
beginning the year I forget he took out
his own teeth took out what's-his-face
there Daniel Ricciardo and they gave him
all this [ __ ] does he need to adjust his
style all these [ __ ] [ __ ] who
don't drive for a living
so he was thrashing all of them going
you should tell Vettel yeah you should
tell him he needs to adjust his style
and then he shouldn't adjust it at all
the way I didn't adjust my style and now
here I sit three races in a row whatever
on the [ __ ] podium you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Kimi räikkönen they kept bringing up
this is his 25th and 26th podium without
winning a race it's like this could
[ __ ] Lewis Hamilton went because glue
is Hammes up my kids sleeping this cos
[ __ ] Lewis Hamilton wins every
goddamn week ok that's like giving
somebody [ __ ] who played when Michael
George
was at the height of his powers he never
got a ring nobody got a ring you know I
got a ring Elijah one with [ __ ] Jordan
was playing basketball and then when he
was a little out of shape the next year
other than that everybody got shut the
[ __ ] down all right that's what happens
so what what I'm what needs to happen is
the next the next straight great driver
has to come around and also for what
might but I little know about the sport
is they gotta [ __ ] get with either
Mercedes of Ferrari basically Mercedes
it seems to have the fastest car out
there because I think what's this I
think Daniel Ricciardo is gonna [ __ ]
he's gonna jump somewhere right that's
what they say I like both those drives
ain't about the eggs the Americans will
be coming like six to seventh we got
some points and our great cars are
overcast cars what else did I do if I
got back on my [ __ ] diet this has
been tough it's been tough to get back
on the diet I felt like Heights I
[ __ ] ate over in France you know had
a couple of slip-ups but I'm back to the
quinoa hittin the elliptical oh god the
first two minutes of getting on the
elliptical at my age Jesus Christ after
that I just kind of go numb and then
it's fine I listen to my [ __ ] songs
and then it's over but I finally got
this shoulder thing beep and I have I
think I have to join a gym though
because in order to rehab my shoulder
where I can do pull-ups again I got to
do those those [ __ ] lat pull-downs
with like 20 pounds then 30 and work my
way up to my body weight and then I can
attempt to do like a pull-up because
what I did last time when I rehabbed it
was I then got these like those helper
bands you know that you stand on and
make the pull-up easier but I was still
you know trying to pull up you know 90
100 pounds with the weight and I [ __ ]
Jack my shoulder again so I got to do
what I don't want to do I got to go join
a [ __ ] gym so I got to find a local
gym not a [ __ ] a chain one cuz those
are the ones they get your credit card
then you can't [ __ ] get out of it let
me tell you that time I went to
Alley's I joined Bally's and it was like
trying to [ __ ] leave AOL he just
couldn't do it they bow okay send in a
hundred dollar cancelation fee and then
I sent it in and then they go oh yeah
yeah but there's another there's another
gym within like a five-mile radius so
you can't cancel like oh and I was like
what the [ __ ] you just you just took a
hundred dollars from me I should have
sued the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of a night and
I didn't so I just didn't pay him I just
you know I did I cancelled the credit
card it was the only way out and it was
it was quiet for months I didn't hear
from anybody then all of a sudden this
collection agency called me up you like
yes William burn the air please and I'm
like this is he they're like hey this is
showing so from the so-and-so collection
agency
we bought your debt from Bally's Total
Fitness and would like to discuss it
with you and I just like well I don't
know what the hell you did that for you
know I didn't pay them what what the
helmet why would I pay you I don't even
know you you know this is your business
he see you actually earn a living doing
this [ __ ] buying debt that other people
can't [ __ ] collect and then so she
was like you know giving me [ __ ] telling
me I had to collect I'm not doing it you
know I go I go I have perfect credit
I've paid everything okay I really don't
think that some day in the future when I
go to buy a house they're gonna be like
you know what we really want to let you
know give you a couple hundred thousand
dollar loan here but you know three
hundred dollars to a gym and she's like
oh my god you know we just had a client
who just called us up and said please
please please I have to pay off you know
this four hundred dollars that I owe you
because I'm trying to buy a house and
they won't let me and I was like wow I
go that's incredible that's almost the
exact same scenario that I just
presented to you it's almost like you
made it up right and then she got
[ __ ] mad at me and then I just
started hitting on her then she started
saying it was harassment and I just
gotta leave you know you live around
here you know you got a boyfriend or
anything and she ended up
mad she hung up on me you know I'll
probably get me to it over that and ever
since then I've been afraid of the phone
every tiny frags I shake but L foods
always on silent anyways well we got 22
minutes in there is it time to [ __ ]
say and you know what I gotta admit they
just kept harassing me and harassed me I
just got sick of it it was only 300
bucks so I just [ __ ] paid him and I
shouldn't have there's a couple people
that I shouldn't have paid and I did but
I just I didn't like the stress you know
I couldn't put it into perspective I
just got sick of them calling me and I
you know I had fun with them [ __ ]
hitting on Omar saying that I got into
some horrible accident that's that was
another big one that I just said I don't
know how many times I have to tell you I
lost my leg in a car accident what kind
of people oh my god sir I'm so I'm sorry
to hear that well are you this is like
the third time I'm literally sitting
here right now with my stump elevated so
I don't believe because the sutures have
come loose again and he you are
harassing is just what you do and then
they would you know it was that thing
and I just ran out of ways to have fun
with them and then I think I just
finally [ __ ] paid him yeah I've done
that a couple times I had a [ __ ]
landlord that stole from my apartment or
a manager stole from my bubs on the road
and I came back and was on the road for
three weeks I was on the road for so
long when I came back like most of the
water had evaporated out the toilet and
they had this checked the smoke alarm so
legally they could go into my apartment
when I wasn't there without my consent
because if there was a fire it could
affect the other units that's what they
said and all of a sudden I noticed there
was a camera missing they picked through
my CDs it was a hip-hop fan and so I
went down and I talked to the guy about
it thinking that the manager was gonna
be like oh my god sir we got to get to
the bottom of this he chooses I don't
appreciate you
downer excusing me and he started saying
like I have the power he kept saying I
have the power so I go yeah you got the
power I buddy and I just stood outside
the office and any time anybody new came
I stood out there for two hours I was
like yeah don't rent from these people
they they stole from my apartment and
all that sand just that's like dude I'm
a comedian I can do this all day I will
be down here every single [ __ ] day
and it was [ __ ] because the next day
I went on the road and I just I just
didn't have it in me and I shouldn't get
a hey come on in here
the lovely Nia everybody come here
what's going on I was just talking to
them about collection agencies and all
of that type of stuff and all the crap
I've gone through I haven't had a lot of
that stuff but you know they have a toy
that I that time that woman called me up
they know his Bally Total Fitness and
they and I just started hitting on her
and she got mad at me said it was a
harassment I ended up getting her to
hang out those up on me that was like
the highlight what's the matter with you
are you doing all right well I got like
another 35 minutes here I'm just gonna
read some advertising and I got some
great questions from people this week
all right do you want to go get some
floss instead of just staring at me with
the hook your fingers in your mouth you
know what's sexy to me you know what's
sexy to me at my age eight hours sleep
that that turns me on all right all
right listen Dee I'd love to talk to you
while you pick your teeth I got to keep
the momentum going here we have floss if
you're gonna get your fingers between
your teeth get out of here there you go
tenacity yeah all right there we go
Jesus they always want to go somewhere
you don't I mean only wants a [ __ ]
house and then you get a one and then
all they want to do is leave ya boy
it's un-fuckin'-believable I when is the
when is the guy me two thing gonna
[ __ ] happen you know what I mean the
reverse me too
you know I take a lot of these feminists
a little more seriously if they ever
bitched about something that didn't
affect their life you know what I mean
let me guess something that affects you
you're self-centered [ __ ] all right
let's uh let's move on here oh and then
I'm gonna tell you about this this music
festival I went to yesterday
definitely feeling my age at a music
festival just having to stand standing
too long throws out my back at this
point I know it's my posture I don't
need you all Yunnan doctors out there
just save me your [ __ ] remedies all
right all right oh here's something from
a friend of mine a buddy of mine he
actually died a couple years ago and his
widow is trying to finish a project that
he started which is a really great idea
it's called the the untold legends of
hip-hop and my buddy Pete coming rested
so he was out there interviewing all of
these legends from the early days of rap
music Kurtis Blow Russell Simmons spliff
star did I say that right and he they
would do these two-minute little stories
talking about the early days of hip-hop
and then they were animating it and I
saw some of the clips and it looked
[ __ ] incredible and they want to
finish this thing so they have a
start-up if you're a fan of hip hop
music animation and all that's not just
cool stuff you like to learn about music
the way I do the website is halo boost H
alo B oo st.com and the project is the
untold legends of hip-hop people go to
halo boosts and click on the featured
project and then you go to the untold
legends of hip
campaigning donate $1 whatever you can
do to try to get this thing made it's a
really really cool project and from one
of the great people that I've met in
this business well I'll definitely
retweet the link and all that type of
stuff so I appreciate it you know if
you're you know if you're into it I'm
not still pressure here all right all
right here we go
butcher box everybody oh these guys
these guys these guys know what that
doing here butcher box delivers healthy
100% grass-fed and grass-finished beef
free-range free-range organic chicken
and heritage breed pork bread brie pork
yeah the incredible quality of butcher
box meat starts with the commitment of
raising animals humanely before they
kill them and free of antibiotics and
hormones I gotta tell you something I
cannot say enough about their heritage
breed pork you gotta get it all right
you've got to do it - skillet sear it on
both sides spin it the finish to the
other come out a little [ __ ] garlic
butter bath III don't give a [ __ ] way
your wife wants to go the next day
you're gonna have a smile on your face
it is [ __ ] delish each box comes with
at least nine to 11 pounds of meat which
is enough for 24 individual sized meals
you can choose from five different box
types I swear to god this is around
there be you know back in the day then
there would have been no Jeffrey Dahmer
all beef beef and chicken beef and pork
mix pour custom box
I'm just saying cuz there's so much of
it you know I'm sorry
you know I used that serial killer
reference and I know they're gonna give
me [ __ ] about it was I was thinking 24
pounds of meat Oh 24 11 pounds of meat I
was just thinking like you know you
double up the order you get one of those
meat freezers in your [ __ ] garage you
know you know Lezama getting people so
they got all that meat it up that that
you know everybody else is starving to
death and you just sitting there going
like yeah I don't know when health
coming and they're looking at you like
well how come you're not getting the
skinny like us right they're like he's
got food but by then they're too weak
and you got all that [ __ ] heritage
breed pork and you all that protein you
[ __ ] knock their asses out right
I don't know man they just want
everything but giant meat frizzy just
always think of a fee you know you just
think of somebody chopping up a body
custom box lets you choose your own cuts
antibiotics /home hormone free butcher
box believes in a healthier food system
where everyone has access to meets the
way nature intended free of antibiotics
and hormones and humanely raised on open
pasture I got it's [ __ ] delicious
butcher box carefully curates the finest
selection and cuts look at that one over
there and makes it a breeze to customize
your own delivery build your own box to
exactly what you want whatever you want
to what your family will love choose
your delivery frequency with
customization customizable subscription
recipes are available on the butcher box
website and videos are available to
follow along on the butcher box YouTube
channel which is great and it says
personal experience I told you I already
told you already told you but I love the
[ __ ] portrait anyways to receive free
bacon for life plus $10 off your order
go to butcher bought what free bacon for
life go to butcher box car they probably
give you a thick slices hoping you have
a heart attack so they got to keep
giving you [ __ ] bacon for the next
five decades to set off your order go to
butcher box.com click on the big bacon
banner on the homepage and use Burpee
URR a checkout go now limited time offer
holy [ __ ] that's next-level
free bacon for life tell me that's not
gonna be a home run me undies everybody
oh do be on dates me undies free bacon
for your life doo doo doo doo me on DS b
undies it's just for you and not your
wife tell that [ __ ] to get her own
you're making some bacon now leave me
alone
I wanted fair and [ __ ] square we got
a bacon [ __ ] prenup and my balls have
feeling nice and soft in my nice tight
Greg look
Naina's pair of underwears you
definitely heard me talk about me undies
hey you guys heard me sing about it you
know the fun comfy undies that feel as
good as they look to those of you who
haven't tried them yet listen up there's
a reason your balls are crying because
all the other balls are walking around
bragging about it you can get incredible
underwear sent to your door with me
undies meaning no more hunting around
for perfect for a perfect pair at a
crowded store and eventually settling
for good enough I guess these don't make
my balls too itchy me undies are made
with sustainably sourced material from
beach wood trees how they make their
underwear out of trees I have no idea
they're naturally soft fiber makes a
fabric that won't sag you know leading
your balls hang in there like the
beginning of an action movie the bestest
Stallone trying to reach down and grab
them or they don't ride up you know like
in some cost of phobic relationship
where it's killing my biological clock
is ticking you twisted my nuts dear
trust me once you put on a pair you'll
get it me undies is so sure you'll love
the first pair that if you're not happy
well [ __ ] they'll do whatever they can
hey guys don't get don't get desperate
here they can to get it right get you
into the right pair and if they can't
keep them and they'll refund you so it
really is risk-free to try your best
underwear ever and if you're already
part of me on these family tell your
friends about it to get there in their
referral program this is like
Scientology but with funk in your balls
they'll get a discount and you'll get a
store credit it's a win-win still not
sure well me undies has a deal for my
listeners first-time purchasers get 15%
off their first pair of me undies and
free shipping that's 15% off case you
didn't hear me two seconds ago plus free
shipping and a guarantee that you and
your me undies will be happy together I
can't see my balls in any other
underwear except B undies get your butt
over to me undies , treat yourself balls
singing to each other right me and you
and you and me no matter how we're in
the sack well though we see each other's
[ __ ] in purple face what color are your
balls I always picture they were purple
I guess they're red
to get you 15% off your first pair
shipping a 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me and acecomm / / that's me
undies dot-com / / I just really so
stupid that [ __ ] song with being in
you and you with me oh my god I got a
lot of reeds this week I got a lot of
singing to do here Oh Dollar Shave Club
do if you ever brush your teeth to try
to make try to make your hair look
presentable here's some good news
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to
help you out do you guys know much money
I save a year on shampoo cuz I shaved my
[ __ ] head Dollar Shave Club yes yes
that dollar stat Dollar Shave Club
delivers everything you need to look
feel and smell your best you name it
shampoo conditioner body wash toothpaste
hair gel even a wipe that will leave you
a touch feeling tingly clean you'll be a
big fan of their amber and lavender
calming body clamp cleanser after the
first time you use it you know those one
white charese are basically the poor
man's bidet and having used a bidet it's
it's [ __ ] I mean the fact that we
still use toilet paper over here it's
it's you know do you know why those
Frenchie's I have in all those
menage-a-trois over there it's because
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] are so goddamn
clean that's what it is
good luck finding a product like that in
a store
Olive Dollar Shave Club products are
made with top-shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget you'll feel the
difference plus shipping is included
with your membership and here's a great
way to try a bunch of Dollar Shave
club's products for just five bucks you
can get their daily essentials starter
set it comes with body cleanser one
wipes
[Music]
they're amazing but wipes their
world-famous shaved butter and their
best razor the six blade executive shave
a gorilla six blades keep the blades
coming for a few more bucks a month and
add in shampoo toothpaste or anything
else you [ __ ] need speaking of your
next month for a limited time only use
the code burr at checkout to get five
dollars off your second month of the
club that's code burr at
dollarshaveclub.com
to save five dollars on your second
month join the club today all right I
said I got two more reads but I'm gonna
give you guys a break all right
yesterday I went to a music festival all
right I went to go see the pretenders
when I was in England the great Chrissie
Hynde came down with some of her friends
some of the band members and stuff they
came down to my show that's the second
time she's come to one of my shows over
there so I was like next time you come
to the u.s. I'm going to your show you
got me I'm going and she said cool guess
what I'm gonna be there a few days after
you come back so I was like all right
done done deal so I figured they're
gonna be playing like some theater or
some [ __ ] out here you know I'm an old
band
I'll sit down in a seat get myself a
sarsaparilla
that'd be once in a while stand up and
wave my fist and feel like I've
contributed as an audience member but no
they were doing a music festival and I
get the email from our man yeah and
there's a map and it's to the Rose Bowl
I'm like holy [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is on
this bill and it was it was Neil Young
Jack White the pretenders the Smiths and
a bunch of other people that I'm sure I
missed and that were [ __ ] amazing
right so I'm like wow this is gonna be I
never saw a concert and at the [ __ ]
Rose Bowl this is gonna be amazing so
you know I walk in there I walked right
words you know the Rose Bowl logo I'm
having all of these flashbacks of how
wait times have been there hammered
going to the Rose Bowl game kind of
struck me as funny to be walking the
golf course it's a big golf course
outside the stadium by the way finally
doing it sober so I'm walking in there
and the first thing I try to go in the
main entrance into the the Rose Bowl
stadium they're like none you got to go
around you got
go around and Michael of course you got
to go around they always make ego the
longest [ __ ] possible way why do I
got to go around
why don't [ __ ] do I got to do that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then I go in there
and then we got to make a left turn and
then a right now I'm gonna cut across
the bridge the stadium's right [ __ ]
there and I go to go cross bridge sorry
sir this is one way it's a it's one way
for walking
are you worried there's gonna be a
head-on collision with a [ __ ] toy after
GUCH guy ain't got to go up there eh and
I'm losing my [ __ ] and then I'm looking
around there's all these tents and all
this [ __ ] and all of a sudden it finally
[ __ ] dawns on me that the concert is
not in the Rose Bowl it's all over this
giant golf course so the whole time I'm
trying to go in the stadium there's
nothing going on in the stadium [ __ ]
[ __ ] right and and also I'm trying to
keep my cool cuz somebody told me other
day said you do not handle stress well
and that of course hurt my ego I'm like
what are you talking about I don't
handle stress well I'm a stand-up
comedian I've performed at Madison
Square Garden I dealt with doing five
minutes of stand-up on the Dave
Letterman Show when it was like 30 below
with the air conditioner okay one of
most intimidating things ever and I was
able to set aside that [ __ ] stress
and get through it and then the person
is like God alright geez I'm just saying
you and then I realized it's like you
know thinking about it the next day
actually snapping again over something
[ __ ] stupid that of course five
minutes later I figured out probably
three minutes later I actually realized
that this person was right that I it's
not I don't handle inconvenience well
and then I turn it into like what's
going on in Hawaii right now with the
lava pouring out and all this [ __ ]
so I've done this so many times the last
couple of days you know except for at
the festival when they I was doing well
with the stress until they told me the
bridge where people were walking was one
way you know I just all right I mean if
I even say that one more time you guys
I'm gonna lose my [ __ ] again so anyways
I drove in traffic yesterday I was
completely relaxed but I've done the
a million [ __ ] times a million times
is somebody says something me about it
it makes me want to change and then for
two-three days I'm okay and then
gradually I just go back to the way I
was you know flipping the [ __ ] out so I
think I want to start talking about it
on the podcast the way I do with my
boozing because I keeps my booze in and
check to tell you guys if I'm on the
wagon I'm off or whatever then you guys
give me shitty Billy booze bag a billion
[ __ ] fat tits and all that [ __ ] makes
me alright [ __ ] these people I'm going
back to crushing waters so anyways I
finally figured out that this festival
is outside and now you know I don't know
where the [ __ ] I'm going and the
pretenders are gonna be on they were on
in the afternoon 525 right right at dusk
or should have been dusk different time
of year would have been dusk right and I
was looking like what the [ __ ] do I do
here I got to get some booze right so
you know they're doing these little
[ __ ] you know they're not pulling at
home for so I got like two whiskey's and
I'm walking on my stupid little cup
right and I see this [ __ ] guy even
older than me he must have been like 63
he's actually still in pretty good shape
but he had the long gray hair he had his
shirt off you know just that guy he's
been going to concerts forever you know
and the pretenders start up and I'm
trying to find whether the you know the
best place where I could watch it and he
starts doing like that you know like
that that [ __ ] hippie surfer
spiritual white guy dancing you knows a
touch of Tai Chi in there you know he's
doing that [ __ ] dance and you know
it's the same dance he does to all music
I don't know what it is and they always
have like this look on their face when
you look in this smiling they always
look at you like they have life figured
out like they know what what makes they
like hey man like you know they're gonna
say oh this spiritual [ __ ] to you
that you could find on the side of a
[ __ ] Dixie cup you know then whoever
that guy is I want to thank you I
[ __ ] was
my ass off just a [ __ ] he had his
shirt off
I get it sit he was still doing that I
got a minute he was still doing the
push-ups so he didn't have the man boobs
but still it's like come on man these
young people here they don't want to see
that cover yourself up
this whole [ __ ] pride in your age and
everything you know or how you look is
all well and good but you know you know
what it's kind of disappeared is common
[ __ ] courtesy for your fellow man
good lord you don't I just blows my mind
it really doesn't it doesn't because you
know what I think that guy was a baby
boomer you know and there's never you
know you know right before the baby
boomer sorry I gotta plug my headphones
back in right before the baby boomers
was the Greatest Generation
according to Tom Brokaw they're the
greatest generation like I think the
baby boomers are like the most selfish
like maybe because there's so many of
them that they had such an influence on
the culture and I think every [ __ ]
thing that happened during that time was
just so goddamn important they're just I
don't know I think and I think that
there were just so up their own ass
about themselves that now that they're
old and all wrinkly they just can't they
can't they just can't let it go can't
let it go you know and then like Alethia
I'm fighting aging by trying to work out
and stay in shape and eat right and all
that type of stuff but yeah I stay
covered up I have empathy for people in
their 20s they they don't want to see it
so anyways I go by the spiritual dancing
guy and I were my way up as close to the
stage as I possibly can and I have to
tell you something man Chrissie Hynde
and the pretenders [ __ ] murdered she
sounded like she said once again two
weeks in a row I've seen great concerts
she sounded it is great as the albums
that I grew up listening to and the song
she opened with was on her for her new
album it was just about being a loner
and
liking not being in a relationship and
[ __ ] and the lyrics are hilarious and I
I'm almost a little ashamed at like how
much I relate to the song I told her
afterwards it was like I [ __ ] love
that song but they just [ __ ] murder
and she's such a badass total rock star
like the real deal paid her dues all
that [ __ ] you just see all of that when
you watch her perform it was tremendous
and she gets offstage and then next up
was Jack White Jack [ __ ] white right
I get to see him come out with his new
lineup the new sound that he has he was
[ __ ] unbelievable Dan you know
there's another guy if you go see him
it's like when have you ever seen that
guy even remotely take a show like half
a second off during a show forget about
a show that guy never is the intensest
of phoning it and whenever I see that
guy perform live I always get inspired
as a comedian like I could be working a
little harder I could be trying to give
people a better show here so his set
ended and I walked over to go see the
Smiths
who I'm one of my brothers listen to
them everybody I knew listened to better
music than I listened to in the 80s I
just was listening to like I mean I
listened to some good [ __ ] but I was
listening to a lot of [ __ ] hair metal
you know which is why I missed out on
Pantera and [ __ ] all those bands that
came out like I was I was I was too far
the other direction like every rose has
its thorn you know it all sounds like a
Polly [ __ ] right I'm just like what
the [ __ ] is this this is you know I'm as
cynical as the next guy but Jesus Christ
that's another thing I started listening
to that Iowa album that Slipknot [ __ ]
and like I always liked the The Heretic
thing people evil [ __ ] I wish so it was
kind of funny but I never like I don't
know it was just too much going on and
now I'm listening to it [ __ ] 20 years
after it came out going like this [ __ ]
album is unbelievable but I mean you
know there's only so much [ __ ] music
acutely you gotta miss something right I
got to forget myself on some level so
anyways I went over and I saw the Smiths
and I remember they want that one song
that crossed over that even like a
[ __ ] mainstream charlie like me heard
where was that stopped the medicine oh
rap stop it's up in yo future right
anyways I watched those guys that band
[ __ ] murdered and did the impossible
I felt it had like 10,000 white people
all dancing for their entire [ __ ] set
it was ridiculous how hard they killed
and then they ended their set in such a
cool way they had this crowd to his
sing-along and the band was started
playing a little more quiet a little
more quiet a little more quiet and and
the lead singer was like roasting people
in the crowd great job great job
you don't sound that good you feel like
he got bronchitis in it and everybody's
laughing and then the band just sort of
just gradually stopped playing and the
crowd one more time sang or was it the
chorus and then they said thanks a lot
good night it was so [ __ ] cool and
and then Neil Young starts playing I got
to walk across the golf course again and
my back was [ __ ] killing me
and I was jet-lagged and all of that
[ __ ] and I just I hate to say this I've
never seen Neil Young in concert I just
couldn't make it you know and I had to
get home you know I got a kids getting
up and [ __ ]
and it's just like I don't want to
[ __ ] see Neil Young standing outside
with my back [ __ ] you know talking to
me next to some [ __ ] 60 year old guy
doing his tight she [ __ ] hey man
dance
I want to see this guy in a theater so I
stood there and I watched him play one
song so I could say or at least most of
the first song he didn't even sing it
was just like him playing guitar and
[ __ ] I think his experience I was like I
got to get all those people that were
just over at the Smith
it's time to come over I'm sure people's
feet hurt and their backs hurt I mean
he's probably doing me a favor but I
just you know I don't know
I just said to my friends I was like
guys I gotta I gotta go home I can't and
I goo bird here and it's just gonna be a
thousand [ __ ] people too and I just
know how I'm wired I have to find that
one-way bridge that's gonna allow me to
get the [ __ ] out of here and I actually
left during one of my favorite singers
of all time during his [ __ ] set but
anyways it's a great show and all that
if you're younger definitely check it
out if you're older definitely stretch
you know try to keep your shirt on I saw
these two people oh my god these two
[ __ ] whales he's too fat people like
one of those fat couples and they were
just asleep on their picnic blanket like
both in like the spooning position but
faced opposite there was like a fat
yin-yang they were just laying there you
know what they look like you know what
like it to Zoo when they tranquilize
like a one of those big cats when those
predators and then it's just like all
right now that we knocked it out we need
to bring a [ __ ] machine over here to
pick this thing up it weighs like 600
[ __ ] pounds and I don't know they were
they were oddly adorable like I was
being like it must be fun you know what
I mean like like those commercials come
out and you see like dominos are like
Papa Gino's will have like a [ __ ]
something like get two pizzas for seven
bucks and if you get that we'll throw in
the [ __ ] chocolate chip cookie pie
with the whipped cream and ice cream
right and I always make fun of that [ __ ]
and I always make fun of it because
there's a big part of me that just wants
to order that and take the ride you know
they have the salt [ __ ] take me down
to the ground right now authorities I
think I'm gonna [ __ ] you know sink
into the rug like that dude and
Trainspotting then he start eating the
[ __ ] cookie pie and you start coming
back like Hulk Hogan you know when he
when they went to drop his hand that
last time and it
go down and all of a sudden you eat the
cookie thing and you start shaking your
head you start strutting around right
but you don't you don't and they get
they get to live that life they get to
sit there like I bet they got one of
those you know those you know those big
[ __ ] couches that on either side
there's the recliner but it's still like
a sofa I bet they got one of those right
and then in the middle it the thing
comes down remember that it was
basically it was a fat [ __ ] couch they
used to make this thing before like The
Biggest Loser and everything came out
was like catering for people who were
fat [ __ ] or were their goal of life was
to become a fat [ __ ] because on either
side of this big couch that I keep you
could pull a lever and your feet could
go up and then in the middle this thing
would come down there's a place for your
drinks and like a [ __ ] pizza and you
just sit there with you with your
girlfriend you know watching the TV with
your feet up got the AC cranked and just
destroy like just destroying the [ __ ]
planet in your absolute like utopia I
mean I don't know if you guys believe in
an afterlife and which I've thought
about a lot when Vinny passed you know
there was all that talk about now he's
Rene Dupree United with his brother and
I was definitely thinking I really hope
that that happens you know so let's say
that it does okay if you're a fat couple
and you have one of those couches and
you're watching one of your favorite
shows on Netflix or Hulu whatever the
[ __ ] you do and you're sitting there
with your feet reclined eating a pizza
and you got that cookie [ __ ] pizza
thing coming next
drinking your favorite drink it's just
like what could the afterlife offer you
that's gonna be any better than that if
you truly love one another you know when
you got the AC going you know you got
your toes out I mean I don't know I
think I'm selling a lifestyle right now
here I think I'm selling some couches
anyways but I had a great time and if
you get a chance you know like I said
definitely check out that festival and I
feel really bad that I had to leave I
left during Neil Young the [ __ ] is wrong
with me I have to I have to fix that in
the future by seeing him but like you
know I want to see that guy like did you
ever see when he did that film he was at
the Ryman that's what you want to see
[ __ ] deal young you see Matt this I'm
not trying to not sell this festival but
I'm just saying look I'm old I need a
chair okay there I said it
alright I used to be able to stand
evidently I can't any longer I was able
to kind of work with work my way out of
it I know it's my [ __ ] posture
posture stinks you know it's all those
years from [ __ ] hating yourself you
don't [ __ ] slinking down I'm an
albino stop looking at me alright endo
chino endo chino talk about how every
man looks better in a suit well you know
when i'm out there trolling for [ __ ] you
know it's just like i hate to be picky
but guys the sweat pants and the lazy
look isn't doing it for me alright if
i'm gonna give it up I want a nice meal
okay so when a guy in a suit comes along
Indo Chino is the world's largest
made-to-measure menswear company and has
been featured in many publications
including GQ Forbes and Fast Company
Fast Company sounds like a bad sitcom
they are old but they're still [ __ ]
snappy they make suits and shirts made
to your exact measurements for a great
fit guys love the whole wide selection
of high-quality fabrics and the option
to personalize all details including
your lapel lining and monogram oh that's
that's that was that was the side of a
badass dude when I was a kid if you had
your initials on your sleeve of your
suit you know got a company car you know
came home your wife looked at the ground
she knew who was running [ __ ] I mean
that was success here's how it looks how
it works sorry visit a showroom our shop
online at endo Chino calm pick your
fabric choose your customizations submit
your measurements wait for your custom
suit to arrive in just a few weeks this
week miles can get any primo indochina
suit for just $379 that's Indo Chino
calm I end do CH I and oh it's like
China but with a no and it's like India
with a no right no it isn't it's like
Indonesia but you don't say the knees
apart and it's like China well you know
when entering per a check out that's 50%
off the regular price for a
made-to-measure premium suit how many
times I guess a made to measure isn't it
made to measurement plus shipping is
free that's endo Chino comp promo code
bar and any print and for any premium
suit for just 379 bucks and free
shipping incredible deal for a suit that
will fit you better than anything off
the rack
ever could you know and it gives you
incentive to stay in shape once you
submit it it's like you can't get fatter
I got to maintain stamps calm everybody
the US Postal Service is an important
tool for any business stamps.com is the
easiest way to access all the amazing
services of the post office
stamps.com never closes print postage
for any lettuce or packages at your
convenience
24/7 print postage for any mail class
right from your own computer the exact
amount of postage every time never under
pay or over pay again
stamps.com saves you time and money
there you go
which you can use to grow your business
by and print official US postage for any
letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer
they'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates the exact
postage stamps telco will even help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs no need to lease these an
expensive postage meter and there are no
long term commitments I use stamps calm
I'm going to use them this weekend
hopefully if my posters get back from
Ireland to pluck and said these things
to Minneapolis and Detroit my exclusive
tour posters 54 my age not my effort all
right
good a hundred percent effort at fifty
years of age and you can only get them
if you go out to the show because I'm
not shipping them out again dealing with
hey man
like a [ __ ] yank thinking they can't
find it right now you two can enjoy the
stamps telecom service with a special
order that includes a four week trial
plus postage and a digital scale go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in BER
that stamps calm and tuber alright we
got some great emails this week the
first one Vinnie Paul hey Bill by now
I'm sure that you heard that Vinnie Paul
passed away last Friday much like you
talked about Malcolm young after his
death I feel like Vinnie was another one
who just lived an amazing life one of
the great drummers to ever get behind
the kid I got to tell you like
everything that I saw on Twitter from
all these big-time rock stars
over and over and over again other than
stating the obvious what a monster
amazing drummer he was everybody just
talked about what a nice guy he was
anyways he said I was too young when
Pantera was leaving their mark on the
metal scene through the 90s so I never
got to see Pantera play live before they
disbanded however I did get to see
Vinnie play with hell yeah back in the
day back in 2016 at Rockville Festival
in Jacksonville Florida
he was quite simply incredible oh this
is a cool story I read this before the
podcast something I never do but I saw
it said Vinnie Paul so I wanted to read
it I said I remember being pretty close
to the front of the stage and Vinnie was
the first band member to come out before
the show started when he stood up behind
the drum kit he had this smile on his
face like he was just really happy to be
there he twirled his drumstick at the
whole crowd so crowd saluted by putting
his fist in the air and then the madness
began but for most of the show I
couldn't take my eyes off of him because
of how good he was oh that's awesome and
even though he was that good the biggest
memory I have of him was that he was
smiling the whole show like he just
loved playing and see seeing people
enjoy themselves as much as he was he'll
be missed by more you will be missed by
more than we know I don't know if that
sentence makes sense if you remember
please crank a Pantera song up as loud
as you can today I'm sure Vinnie will
hear it the best which is a best which
is incompetent it said
well ours already listen to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] every day anyways you know with you
it's a great album great live album is
there 101 proof it's such a badass album
one of my favorite things is when they
play I'm broken and fill as Phil's doing
the intro video Vinny's already counting
in this song just how tight they were
he's like well sorry but knots called
are broken I'm having a good time
well I'll bet I kept it all alright Coco
the gorilla oh I saw this too that
[ __ ] sweetheart of a gorilla that I
did the bit above hey Bill I saw you you
live last year and I love you special we
talk about teaching gorillas sign
language
I was watching clips of Coco interacting
with people like with flee from the
Chili Peppers and robin williams i
watched those i was still nervous and I
just saw a flea laying down and there's
like a [ __ ] gorilla right next to him
I don't know I get you shooting the [ __ ]
with it you can kind of I don't know it
made me nervous you know I wonder if it
made me nervous just because I'm such a
big fan of flee and I didn't want to see
think happened to him like it was a bass
player from a band I didn't give a [ __ ]
about and they go look at this guy this
could get interesting anyways it was it
was charming as hell I was wondering if
you ever sat down with Coco if ever
given a chance well no not after the bit
I did they probably this guy's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you could have asked him why the chicken
crossed the road and wait for a chuckle
or try to explain humor to him if I ever
sat down with that gorilla I in that
thing actually if that wasn't a party
trick if it actually knew how to do sign
language I imagine it would sign to me
you seem nervous at our back yeah well
you're a [ __ ] gorilla anyways kids
show recommendation hey there Billy
particle balls I want to I want if you
want a show to watch with your
girlfriend check out
I thought I said octo nuts like
something with eight balls octo nuts
is it an octopus in outer space I
watched it with my girls and kids and I
actually learned some stuff all right
well that was about as vague as the
wasn't that was a movie way back in the
game the silent game of the the
something game of the something-or-other
remember David Spade had that joke I'm
gonna tell you I'm going to tell you
guys the secret of The Crying Game
and he goes overrated all right hair
transplant depression
oh no hey old freckle dick I'm a 21 year
old man I recently got a hair transplant
surgery well you must be a hairy
[ __ ] man you went bald that or
soon the surgery went great
good good for you but I now hate that I
have a huge scar in the back of my head
I don't think do it now would they just
vacuum the [ __ ] out so you don't have to
have that smile on the back of your head
you guys every time I cut my hair you
can see it could you give me some advice
on what I should do
well yeah don't cut your hair so [ __ ]
short no you got it back on top of your
head grow your hair out you'll be fine
that was an easy one what are you doing
you got hair plugs
yet I'm hack the back of your head then
you got [ __ ] hair plugs and now
you're shaving your head down to the
point where you can [ __ ] see it
anyways what was the point I don't know
I would just I guess I would just grow
my hair out a little bit I don't think
it has to be that long to cover the scar
as long as it's long enough that you
can't see your scalp I think you should
be alright right anyways pitbull
problems dear Guillaume Burress AFS Eve
Oh Billy easy shave butter oh for seal
his face right no that's easy for seal
is easy I don't know I've no idea I suck
at that [ __ ] as a former pit bull
I'd like to ask your advice on a problem
I'm having my wife comes home from a my
wife comes from a large family and they
get together at her parents every month
for Sunday dinner and family hangouts
the last two times my brother-in-law has
brought his recently a duck he's
recently adopted pitbull it's a rescue
dog and he doesn't think it was abused
or used to fight because it's so good
with kids according to him it's a large
family so there there are about 15 kids
ages 3 to 11 running around and my
four-year-old daughter is one of them
she loves dogs and likes this one in
particular but both times he's brought
my the dog my daughter has come running
to me in tears because it got
overexcited and jumped on to her - ruff
well that's the thing about pity's man
they're just a big [ __ ] awesome ball
of muscle and when I used to wrestle
with my dog I used to have to lay my
neck over the top of its neck he had to
get inside because she was lightning
quick and she would turn around and her
head was like a wrecking ball god I
missed that [ __ ] dog I still get to
see her every couple months but I really
missed that
anyway she goes I don't hate dogs but I
don't love them either and I don't trust
pit bulls well you have to validate all
of that okay to be quite honest I'm kind
of afraid of them I'd never forgive
myself if something happened to my
daughter if I say something to my
in-laws I look like a killjoy [ __ ]
but I'm too stressed out to enjoy the
family gathering because I'm hovering
over her constantly so my wife's
response has been to treat me like I'm
overreacting and dismissed my concerns
it's bothering me so much I've
considered just keeping my daughter home
next time but am I making too big a deal
about this I think it's a recipe for
disaster I don't feel like it's my place
to tell my brother-in-law to keep it at
home and my wife's not supporting me
please tell me please let me know if you
have any ideas merci Ava thought to fair
for two thank you thank you and I
imagine that saying go [ __ ] yourself I
know advise and go
says you favorite alright anyways I
would say this dude you have to put like
if that's what you're feeling you don't
have to tell anybody to leave a dog home
right you just have to communicate this
to people
alright say you don't hate dogs you
don't love him either and you don't I
don't trust pit bulls okay and just tell
them that rather be like he did [ __ ]
let me take those I'll just tell them
that all right and I would sit down with
your wife and say that you know I don't
feel like you're hearing me
all right she's my daughter and I'm
concerned and I have to be honest you
know if you had these concerns I would
listen to them and you're not validating
what I'm feeling and it's really
bothering me and I can't enjoy when I go
over there I don't want to be this
killjoy but I'm hovering over our kid
and I just you know it's bothering me
you married me you loved me I'm telling
you something's bothering me we need to
talk about go there because I have you
and you [ __ ] talk to me about this
that's what I would do keep it in the
register I was just in alright and don't
stop having the conversation until
there's a solution that you're satisfied
with it's your daughter okay
and you know dogs are abused alright and
if a dog snaps you know it's a bad thing
around a kid and then when you have a
pitbull the thing about a pitbull is its
capability you know what I mean
some dogs that like a little water
pistol and other dogs are like a [ __ ]
bazooka
that dog is a bazooka so not saying the
breed is bad I'm just saying if somebody
[ __ ] that dog up and it does snap the
results are you know gonna be really bad
so and you have to address that that's
being or being a responsible parent and
these people need to listen to you and
you need to speak up you gotta stand up
for yourself there buddy boy that's my
advice
all right good luck okay lady lady
manager crossing the line dear bill or
William but we'll call yourself a little
below will I'm a 23 23 year old lady who
just started working in an office for I
love when women write in it's always
guys god bless you for writing in who
just started working in an office for a
big company it's a boring job but while
I figure out what to do with my life
after graduating it's all right well
there you go
that's not bad you're 23 got your whole
life at you I got promoted with the
recommendation from my former manager
there's 40 something year old woman who
I thought was quite nice now that she's
not my manager anymore although she's
still senior to me she has been a little
inappropriate with me after an office
Christmas party me and my colleagues
went to a club I came out of the club
bathrooms and she was waiting she didn't
even come with us that's weird
she waved me over to sit next to her and
asked me if I was gay I said no I'm not
and she went fine and didn't speak to me
for the rest of the night all right well
she needs a better opening line she's a
little blunt you know she's in business
she got right down to brass tacks she
said I was a bit uncomfortable with the
question because what business is it of
hers oh I thought she was gaged she
wanted to hook up with you because what
business is it of her so I told one of
my work pals what had happened they had
been at the company longer than me and
went wow you're her new one then oh boy
oh gee jeez
I asked them what they meant and a guy
said well I mean look at her right now
she's filming you and she sure enough
what and sure enough she was she was
when I turn around she hit her phone as
I was a little bit too drunken under the
influence I was already paranoid so I
decided to leave because I felt so gross
since then she's pulled me aside to say
that I looked delicious and scrumptious
oh what a crepe whenever she sees me at
the end of the day
she taps her cheek and demands a kiss oh
yeah what the [ __ ] is this purse she
ain't that's cool that's like a gross
relative she asked a girl who works for
me to take pictures of me and to send it
to her when we're at a pub I consider
myself an assertive girl but there's
something about how public about her
actions which makes me so timid so I go
along with it no don't do that you think
you would think that because she's not
my manager anymore now that I've been
promoted it wouldn't be a problem but it
is because my new manager is our best
friend I don't want to cause a rip in
this new job but it's really stressing
me out
am i within my rights to tell her to
stop absolutely you are I know I tell it
is that no I don't kiss her on cheek
every time I see you without looking
like a [ __ ] listen the way you're
looking at this is [ __ ] crazy you're
you're sitting here looking at like like
you're being an [ __ ] you're not this
person is completely out of line she
said a few of my friends thinks it's a
funny situation but I don't and if you
don't then it isn't
you got to validate that if this was a
male manager he'd be reported I love
your stuff so much and I wish I could
come back to you'd come back to Glasgow
some day from a fellow fellow pasty
redhead all right there fellow [ __ ]
pasty this is what you got to do she
asked for a kiss you tell her no and I
just stare I mean listen you have all
the [ __ ] power in the world or if you
just want to go to the manager and say
listen I don't want to cause some me to
scandal or any of that [ __ ]
can you keep this weird old [ __ ] bag
away from me and tell her to be
professional I mean that's the proper
way to do it those are the proper
channels but I have to do it that way
do it that way okay do it that way and
and and document that this has been
happening you have all these witnesses
about them filming her and all of this
type of [ __ ] if they ever tried to fire
you I mean you don't have a problem with
this this kind of thing needs to stop
and you know in a perfect world you'd go
to her because I don't like that hotel
and honor thing but that's how the
business world works you know in a
perfect world when she [ __ ] goes like
pointed to her cheek yeah that's right
we should punch her [ __ ] blaster
right her [ __ ] face yeah I mean if
you're ever in a bar again and she's
doing that [ __ ] I would [ __ ] dump a
drink right over her [ __ ] head like
that's just creepy behavior I would just
you got to stop this timid thing because
if you timid someone like that is it's
gonna it's like a magnet they're gonna
go right towards you you got to step up
too and tell her what a [ __ ] creep
she is and if I catch you taking video
or pictures of me or any other saw the
[ __ ] creepy sexual [ __ ] that you're
doing I'm gonna report you okay and you
think you're gonna get together with
your [ __ ] manager friend okay all I
got to do is go on social media and your
[ __ ] world is over when the [ __ ] is
my phone whatever [ __ ] it anyways but
don't do that that's all anger listen
you but you know you you seem like a
really like overly nice people please in
person at 23 which I was where you're
like is it me that the way I'm dressing
that's attractiveness it's not you it's
that person okay so whatever the [ __ ] I
said before I got upset
[Music]
just go listen I got an issue don't be
listening I do any kind of define
anything go in there [ __ ] flat-footed
and look right at that person and say
listen I got an issue with her she's
coming at me in weird sexual ways and
I'm getting sick of it
and I'm sick of it I want to come here
and go to work and do a great job I
don't need that okay I would like to
file an official report on her harassing
me okay and that's the deal and I want
it to stop it stops right now
are we clear that's it that's it
there's no don't go in there [ __ ] hat
in hand you don't have to be a [ __ ] just
go in and just say look this is
happening and it needs to stop
immediately okay well I mean what if she
just flashes your kitchen yummy what the
[ __ ] he gonna say you can't say that
it's over right all right good luck to
you
okay stay out of the Sun and the rest of
you go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in
on you on Thursday rest in peace Vinnie
Paul